in America where you live can determine
how long you live you can get shot
anything in a blink I so yeah so that
can't be yeah that can consume you
sometimes heart problems high blood
pressure all kind of things to some
extent the lifespan gap between rich and
poor exists everywhere but when New York
University Medical Center studied the us
the biggest disparity was here in
Chicago that gap is surprisingly wide
even where the distance is short on the
north side among the gleaming high-rises
of the city's Streeterville neighborhood
the average lifespan is 90 years 15
kilometers away in impoverished
Englewood it's sixty that is Larry
Richards age you know in Englewood you
beat the odds right all my life in
Englewood money which leads to better
health care or no health care least a
better food better diet and rich people
are just more aware of their bodies than
poor people where they care more about
it and they can afford the health care
exactly in Streeterville residents have
easy access to medical care healthy
foods and a safe place to exercise here
you can essentially buy a longer life
because here is segregation and poverty
go hand-in-hand people on the south and
west side have been hit by all the ills
here in society like say the gun
violence is off the charts
a lot of people are depressed you have a
drug addiction that's running rampant on
the west and south side of Chicago some
blame access to health care some blame a
lack of healthy foods but researchers
say the biggest cause of shorter life
spans stress has what they call a
weathering effect chronic disease sets
in earlier if people have a rough life
who've been pushed around their whole
life and are being bullied their whole
life and so what you get is a
physiological reaction to being in some
ways a victim of a lot of the social
distribution of status in our society
and there is a element of class to this
and there's an element of caste meaning
race as long as that divide remains
researchers say so will a lifespan gap
john hendren algae's
Chicago